Here at St. Vladimir's,
we all know the
dangers that lurk
outside our gates.
I want to do my sworn duty.
I want to protect my best friend
from danger.
And I want a life
to call my own.
I would never bet against you,
Rose Hathaway.
You must prepare Lissa
for her new role
as head of the Dragomir family.
And Rose?
She'll do her duty.
I'm the royal princess
that needs protecting.
Rose gives and gives
and I take and take.
But I can be a leader who ruled
not just for the royals,
but for all citizens.
Whether you wear
the crown or not,
you have the power
to change things.
There's something
strange happening.
I think I can help you.
Christian is a nonstarter
for a lot of people.
I'll be discreet.
Of course I want
to put you first.
But I can't.
You can either be
guardian or friend.
Not both.
What's the game plan?
You know me.
More of a roll with
the punches kind of girl.
The ruler is not
just any monarch.
Leadership requires
sacrifice for the greater good.
I need to fight.
We need to fight.
They must be willing to give
everything they have.
We deserve a better future.
They're here.
She's my family.
I would die for her.